Wonderful. Okay.
Awesome.
Okay. We're back.
We're back in business, the same place.
Ilan, what are the earned secrets
that over these 20 years,
if you go back 20 years,
what would you tell young Ilan?
With regards to enterprise software,
it's really important
to focus on the end users.
This is something that
we didn't know 20 years ago.
It's maybe a little bit more obvious now,
but that's something
that's critically important.
I think what's more relevant now,
which is interesting,
is that everyone seems to know
that the enterprise software also
has to be designed well.
And, adoption metrics
have to be taken into consideration.
But we have seem to forget the fact
that enterprise software still
has something different from consumer,
which is, enterprise software,
has a user and a chooser.
And it is important.
The chooser is the person
who makes the budget decisions,
the person who makes
the buying decisions.
It is important to consider them
in product management
just as much as the end user.
Why is that?
So, if I buy, I have a sales cycle.
I go to the enterprise.
I pitch to the director who has
the authority to sign of
on a hundred thousand dollar license.
And, but the users are the team players
who at the end are the ones running around
and using my software
for whatever they're doing.
Right.
So, the dynamic is that in this day,
enterprise software is more coming up,
sorry, from the bottom up
rather than top down.
So, rather than CIO making a decision
and saying,
"Everyone is going to use this."
Enterprise software is actually
being found by those ICs,
those individual contributors
that have the jobs, and they want
to be more productive at work.
They're looking for tools
to make them more productive at work.
So, that's why it's important
to focus on the end user.
But, and a lot of
enterprise software companies,
of course, like Slack, are doing so.
But it's important at the same time,
one of the things that people
maybe don't realize about Slack
is that we focus equally on the top down.
What is it going to be important
for the enterprise buyer.
And for Slack
and for productivity tool specifically,
that is productivity and innovation.
What are the tools that are going to help
my employees transform themselves
to be more productive,
to be more innovative.
Going back to that,
because it's fascinating to me.
What you're saying is that,
there has been a trend changing,
that if previously
you go to the ICO of the company, the CIO
and you go and you pitch a product
and you get them to buy into it,
and then from top down
they disseminated into their
thousand employees or so.
Today, you're going after
the team players.
And if they love your product,
they'll start adopting it
throughout the organization
until there's no point but to actually
get it custom for the organization, right?
That's right.
And then, it bubbles up into the CIO.
The CIO sees it.
It's known maybe
as shadow IT at this point.
And now, you want to
use an enterprise software company
you want to sell to the CIO.
This is when the CIO
is going to look for different things.
Their requirements
are very very different
from the end users.
Certainly they want their end users
to be productive.
But they also have to look
after beyond cost.
They have to look after compliance,
security, administration, performance.
Those are the things
that really matter to them
when they're shopping for software.
So, you have to make sure
that your product
also addresses these needs.
Fascinating.
So, it sounds to me like
you're almost developing two products.
Because even, let's look at Slack
as a collaboration tool, on one hand,
you have the end user, which is myself.
I love sharing my files.
I love all the marketplace
with integrations.
My life is nothing like it was
five years ago.
If I had Slack in high school,
my high school would look
extremely different than it does now.
Because now, it's incredible.
I'll just say that it's incredible.
But, there's all of this
in compliance and security
that I'm not even aware of.
For example, I work at Hippo
and I don't really know what security
goes behind the scenes to make sure that
the data that I pass along is secured.
But I'm sure that my CIO
knows it very well, right?
Right. Exactly.
That sounds incredible.
That's exactly right.
And early on in Slack,
we actually did that.
We actually, and I've spoken
to many enterprise software companies
that are starting up,
and given this advice is that early on
we actually separated
our product management into self-service
and into enterprise.
And the self-service part
of product management really focused
on metrics like adaption,
usage of different app features, NPS,
and satisfaction of end users,
the love of the product and all that.
In the enterprise side,
the side that I led,
focus exclusively on making sure
that new industries, new geographies
can actually obtain this software.
Each one has a different
set of compliance requirements,
security requirements,
administration requirements.
So, that's how we looked at the market
in a very different lens.
But Ilan, your colleague has the luxury
of having data from millions of users
getting NPS scores through logic,
through the usage.
You're coming in and you have a handful
of large customers that you're trying
to get information,
from how do you get an NPS score
from those individuals
who are buying the software.
Because every product costumer
that I ever talked, they told us,
"Your customers don't know what they want."
"Ask them what they need."
Right?
So, how do you go about that?
Because your metric is their satisfaction.
Yeah, that's right.
So, by the way, that phrase
that you just quoted
has many times been misconstrued,
especially recently.
And I want to make sure
that people listening to this that are
starting enterprise software companies,
understand that,
yes, that is true.
That customers don't necessarily know
the solution.
They will ask for something
that sounds like the solution.
But what you need to do as a good PM
is to bring them back to the problem.
State the problem, and then your job
is to come up with a solution.
But a lot of people
misinterpret that statement
that you had, to the customers
don't know what they want.
I know better what they want.
I will go and build something
without talking to them.
That is not the right strategy
and will not work.
So, the answer to your question,
it's a really good question.
With enterprise software, it's different.
You can't do a broad survey.
So, quant work is not going to really work
because you just don't have
that many data points.
Exactly.
But you can certainly go
and talk to people.
So, the first thing that I recommend
for enterprise software company
product managers to do
is to set up a CAB.
A customer advisory board.
Bring in your top 20 customers,
meet with them on a regular basis.
Once every quarter, once every six months,
whatever makes sense for you.
Present to them.
What we do with our CABs
and what we've done since
really four years ago when I joined Slack,
is we meet regularly.
We present the road map,
and get their feedback
on what we are showing.
We have special sections.
The next section of the CAB,
it's a one day session usually.
The next section is really to talk about
three different drill-down areas,
areas that we're planning on invest
in recently or in the near future.
And we really want to get their input on
to drill-down into specifics.
And then, the last section is really
for them to talk to us
and hear their feedback
and to talk to one another.
So, the best part of the of that day
a lot of times is just having them
talk to us and again to each other,
about things that are working,
things that are not working,
things that they've tried,
and learning from one another.
And we learn from them as well.
One of the best parts of the day.
Are these pro-users in the sense that
do they love Slack?
Or, is that something
that's common among all of them?
Or, are some of them
a little bit more hesitant?
So, in this case, these are all people,
that's not a criteria that I use.
It's not a litmus test that I use
for getting people on the CAB or not.
They happen to mostly love Slack
because they are responsible
for rolling it out in their organization.
One thing that is important to remember
in enterprise software is that,
those admins, they're your champions.
Those admins, the people that are
working with your software
and managing your software.
They've staked their career
on the success of your product
because that's their career.
And so, it's important to listen to them.
It's important to treat them well.
And so, they do mostly love Slack.
They are mostly champions.
But that's not what I, yeah,
I don't ask that question.
Ilan, what happens
when there's a clash?
There's a clash because
you have road map for enterprise,
your colleague has a road map
for the self serve,
there's a finite resources
as in any organization,
and now you have to make some decisions.
How do you quantify the impact
of these two fields which are connected
but disconnected?
Yeah. A lot of it is art
more than science.
Especially when you're talking about
enterprise to enterprise.
Security to admin, it's pretty easy.
Right?
You just look at the TAM,
or the revenue impacted,
or the pipeline that's blocked
based on the features.
We have reports that show us exactly
how much pipeline is associated
with these big security features
or big administration features.
That's easy on the retail side.
It's also pretty easy because the numbers,
the metrics tell you where to invest.
We have a lot of experiments
that we run there
and see which one proves
to be better enterprise. To reach out
is a little bit more difficult.
And for that, what we've done is,
we have company priorities.
There are always somehow, there are three,
that there are three company priorities.
And you're your initiative
similar to a company pitching to a VC.
We pitch internally.
And it has to align
to one of these three initiatives.
And if it does, then those are the teams
that get the resources for the year.
So so cool.
I'm so upset that were
more than halfway through.
Because every question that you answer,
I have 10 more questions that I wanna ask.
I'll try to keep them short.
No no. This has been perfect.
Please don't.
Ilan, looking back now,
or actually looking forward,
we can't avoid the fact
that we're in the global pandemic
and the world has changed forever.
And our workforce has changed forever.
I'd love your take on where are we headed
in terms of collaborative tools,
productivity, as the world is shifting
more and more towards remote collaboration
either Slack or off Slack.
How do you perceive
our collaborative nature digitally
as the years are going to go for it?
Yeah. Well, so, it's certain that this,
we're not going to go back
to whatever normal was.
I do think that the office
is not a thing of the past.
We will have offices again.
We will all be in offices.
It will be slightly different.
I think we've all realized that people
can actually just be
just as productive at home
as they can on the office,
minus taking care of kids and all that.
But we'll go to a world
where kids are at school
and parents can work.
But I think that the thing that is,
that the trend that we've seen,
and this happened before covid by the way,
is that responsibility and authority
for decision making is brought down
the org chart, right?
It used to be that decisions went up.
And they were made at the top.
And then, those orders came down.
But that's, it's almost reversed.
Decisions are being made in teams.
And what's important for executives
is now to understand all the decisions
that are being made,
so they can better align
and guide the team.
And that's a healthy thing.
That's good for large organizations
to function that way.
And I see in my work with organizations
that are transforming themselves,
that more and more of them
are working to that.
But I think that that is,
now that kind of reverse information flow
is a new area
that's going to be explored with tools.
I don't think that that's an area
that really has been explored
with enterprise software.
That is so so cool.
Okay. And now, 20 years later,
you're still in enterprise software,
collaborative tools, productivity tools,
where are you going to go
into your 21st year?
I mean, what does it do for you
that you're in this unique space
and in your unique position?
Yeah. I'll tell you.
And I don't mean
to bring this back to Slack.
We can talk about other things.
But specifically, four years ago
when I joined Slack
and I went and visited my first customer,
and it's a large bank
in the East Coast.
And I met with an employee there.
And she told me,
"I love my job more
because I use Slack."
Not, I love Slack.
Which would also be great to hear.
And I hear that a lot.
But I love my job.
I'm here nine to five.
I enjoy what I do day to day more
because of this tool.
I'm happier here.
When you can have that kind of effect
on most of the waking hours of a person,
their time away from their family,
that is rewarding.
That's a mission
that I'm happy to get behind.
Slack is just one example of companies
that are doing things like that.
Making people's lives easier
and better at work.
And are you, is it more in the fact
that you're more curious
about enterprise software
that you decided to focus on that space?
Or, do you see yourself
ever shifting to the self serve?
I get it.
I get enterprise software,
I don't get consumer software.
You build something,
and then either someone likes it.
Like you need a 14 year old
to like your product
and then all of a sudden,
other people like it.
I don't get that world.
I definitely get enterprise software.
I love it. I love it.
Okay. Ilan, give me the broad picture
of collaborative tools.
Are we all moving more to
real time communication,
multiple integrations?
Because it seems to me,
it seems obvious that
this is where we're headed.
Is it more that we're going to see
greater productivity using these tools?
Are we going to see more happiness levels
or more satisfaction?
Because I feel pretty productive
right now, I have to say.
I have about a dozen Slack channels
from 10 different segments and workspaces,
and I feel pretty productive
and I'm wondering whether there is,
now the aim is to increase my productivity
or increase my happiness level?
Yeah. I think they both go hand in hand,
by the way.
I think that people could be
both productive and happy.
I think a lot of times
they actually complement each other.
So, if I'm able to be more productive,
I'm able to be get more satisfaction
out of my job.
So, I wouldn't think of happiness as like
just socializing at work or happiness as,
there is happiness
from doing the work itself.
I think, as far as where we're going,
let me first take a quick second,
I can't ever imagine going back to email.
I mean, I can't ever imagine
in fact, I would use this
as definitely a show stopper
in any future company I go to.
I couldn't imagine coming in the morning
and opening up an inbox,
and sorting through 100 or 200 emails
like I used to.
It just seems so counterproductive
to have my information
sorted by someone else based on
what subject they wrote
and when they sent the message.
With Slack in-channels,
I dictate where I work
and what's important to me.
I'm subscribing to the channels
that are most important to the projects
that are most important.
And I'm in control of my day.
It's just, it's so backwards for me
to think about email right now.
As far as where we're going in the future,
I think that there's no question.
You can see this with what slack,
you can see teams, of course,
the Capito's, but whatever.
You can see
the channel based communication,
this type of subscribing to the project
and the topics that I care about,
is the way to the future.
By the way, email is not different
as far as the information that it carry.
E-mail also had topics.
Everything that you did in email
was a topic.
You were hiring someone.
You were working on a project.
You were working on a campaign.
You had a channel
Exactly.
It just was disorganized.
It was just organized chronologically
based on when people sent you messages.
It just isn't organized well.
So, Slack is not like
this is new type of work.
It's just now organizing your work
based on topics.
And one of the really inspiring things
that I've experienced recently
is using superhuman as a client,
because they managed to reduce
the formality of the email.
Up until now, I felt an email,
I felt this great responsibility,
like it's so formal,
Dear Sir, and not simply as Michael.
Now with superhuman,
the way that they did at the chat based,
same thing with Slack.
When my manager here at Hippo Slack's me,
I  feel the informality.
It feels like an ongoing conversation
with the same content
that I would otherwise get in an email.
It makes me respond faster.
It makes me more confident.
All of a sudden I use emojis
in my messages.
I love using emojis.
It sounds like a joke,
but it's a serious thing.
It makes everything more fun.
Yeah. Yeah. I agree.
And more productive.
We use emojis, by the way,
for productivity.
So, when someone wants my attention
in a channel, they put a file
or something like that.
I will use the eyes emoji
to say that I'm looking at it.
And that spells in like calm down,
I'm looking at it.
I didn't miss your message.
And then when I'm done,
I put a green checkbox emoji
saying it's done.
I finished my assignment, whatever it is.
And that way they know,
okay, this is done.
I'm starting to employ that with the team
that I'm on right here.
Yeah.
This was so, thank you for your time.
Thank you for the generosity.
This is so good.
I know how busy you are.
Before we leave, I need three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay. Three words.
So, there's one word that,
However you want to do this.
There's one word that actually means
like all three together,
which is Kibbutznik.
I mean, I grew up in Ein Hod
and moved to Minnesota at age 10.
But the hard working,
collaborative and humble
are things that I aspire to be in my job.
And I learned those all
before the age of 10.
Wow.
Well, kibbutznik said at all.
You gave me the three words
anyways afterwards.
I love it.
Ilan, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
We didn't even mention
the whole about J-Ventures
and working together.
And I think it's been such a pleasure
doing some due diligence with you.
And I've been learning a lot from you
and everybody else.
But thank you for your time,
for this, and for the fun.
And I look forward
to maintaining this relationship.
Thank you.
My pleasure. Thank you.
Bye bye.